back in august i started a big project
with 3d printing i've always wanted to
get a copy of said there's a catan and i
went on amazon i started to buy it it's
like 50 bucks or something like that
it's kind of expensive for a board game
and all the reviews were really bad
turns out that the newest version of the
game is all printed on like cheap
cardboard stock and off-center printing
usually and cut poorly and just so many
complaints but somebody made these great
3d models on thingiverse that you could
download and you could print out it just
seemed like such a perfect project to do
so i started printing them and i told
myself i'm going to print them all in
the highest quality possible so each one
of these tiles took six hours to print
and i have to print a lot of them
it took a month to print everything
finally have it all done it's all white
all the tiles look like this
they look great you know for what they
are but now i need to paint them we'll
have a link in the description below for
these specific tiles if you guys want to
go check them out big thanks to the
creators who made them thingiverse is
great it's just such a cool spot for
people to like design and make tools or
little inventions and then just share
them with other people it's really cool
there's some cool special things about
these tiles and here's the coolest thing
underneath here there's all these little
holes and you put little buckyball
magnets or those little bulb magnets in
those holes what's supposed to happen is
you can stick these together and they go
and they snap like they don't really
hold each other up or anything like that
but there's a very very light attraction
the idea is that ball magnets can spin
because you know there's a north and
south side to magnets and you can't lock
them in there because you don't know
which which other polarity your magnets
will have on the other pieces so little
balls can spin in place to lock
themselves together uh when i printed
all these though i fitted the whole
thing before trying to put magnets into
one of them and all the holes were a
little too big all the magnets would
fall out i solved it by putting a little
bit of wood putty i could put the magnet
in there and put a little bit of wood
putty over the top of it not like
pushing it into the hole but just
covering the top and then i would take
like a tool of some sort like one of
those little screwdrivers that you get
like with like to fix like glasses or
phones or something like that and i just
scrape a little bit off back off the top
and that'd be enough to kind of like
jiggle the the ball loose i actually had
a really powerful magnet that could also
then take and kind of like move on the
edges to wiggle the ball and break it
feed from the putty and after doing so
it worked great and all these little
bucky balls rotate in their sockets they
don't fall out and the whole thing
sticks together so it's really easy just
like put all the pieces together because
all just snap right into place done and
trust me like without the magnets
everything keeps shifting and sliding
it's almost impossible you can see like
right here i'll just take this piece and
just kind of slides right in there super
satisfying
time to do it i haven't been much of a
lens guy for the last few years i
respect lenses but i haven't been very
picky about lenses uh previously for the
last few years we've been using
exclusively canon lenses just because we
we have a ef mount on the red it's very
convenient however lately we've been
shooting a lot in 6k and now with 8k
kind of looming over our heads we've
been experimenting with some higher
quality lenses
we have something really special in the
studio we have the full set of sigma's
cinema lenses and i'm going to compare
them to all the lenses that we are
currently using just to see
what the big what the big deal is about
are our lenses good enough or have we
been using garbage and these super cool
cinema lenses are actually the way to go
let's figure it out there's pros and
cons to everything but that's what this
experiment is all about let me just show
you the lenses we're going to be working
with today 70 to 200 one of my favorite
lenses it's just a great lens we also
have the l series 24 prime and then just
for kicks we got a 17 to 55 whatever
series i don't know this is like this is
not your this is not your grandma's lens
test get ready this is sam's lens test
that's right no standards no particular
order
no information or technical specs
sam slapping cameras lenses on cameras
anyways we and then we've got one of
canon's cheapest lenses here a 50 mil
prime so for the sigma lenses we're
gonna compare we have six of their
cinema prime lenses in here this is a
whopper of a case damn we actually have
two more up here two of their cinema
zoom lenses i know how much these lenses
cost these are way more expensive way
better lenses than anything we are using
so i'm hoping for some good results if
they don't deliver i'm gonna be
disappointed because look at these
things
holy crap we got like a 135 we have we
have the whole range everything except a
50.
so that's cool and then above here 18 to
35
we got a 50 to 100. once again the only
thing i have to compare these two are
the canon lenses that i've been using
for years if their size and weight is
and in any way proportional or relative
to their quality compared to these other
lenses then i have very high hopes
you can buy the game for like 40 or 50
bucks you print it theoretically for
free well for the cost of plastic but
looking back on it now i've put so much
plastic into this and so much time and
paint and like buying all the brushes
and i still have to buy the cards from
the game pack you can buy replacement
cards i had to buy officials so there's
like a 10 cards i'm not saving any money
in fact i'm probably spending more money
than it would take to buy the game but
i'm still doing it when i was really
young i always wanted something like
this you know these days maybe my
imagination's not quite as uh boundless
as it was when i was four years old but
i think it's good to hold on to a little
bit of your youthful attitude especially
if you're in something like art you're
always trying to capture people's wonder
and their imaginations and you know what
could be if you lose sight of that you
know if you're too concerned with the
day-to-day you don't take a moment to
think about what it is that catches
people's wonder and makes them imagine
and it's gonna be really hard to make
art that catches people's wonder and
makes them imagine
the other thing is i spend a lot of time
on computers and for some reason in
today's culture everything's getting
upgraded everything's getting updated
all the time things break constantly
because of that it used to be that you'd
upgrade things to fix them now things
are just constantly breaking
then you sit there and spend half an
hour figuring it out troubleshooting and
at the end of the day you just want to
create like i just want to do my effects
on the computer i just want to edit but
i end up spending 20 of my time every
time i sit down just troubleshooting
stuff but you don't have to troubleshoot
paint you don't have to troubleshoot
paint brushes there's no glitches
there's no errors there's no internet
connectivity required there's no drm
there's no signing in there's no loss of
internet connection it's just you and
the paint
and your hands and it's such like a
calming quiet thing to do to not really
be productive for once just to do
something analog but still make
something that captures your imagination
that feels like it's art
yeah
so all my lens tests went really really
well in fact they gave me the confidence
to take all these lenses and bring just
these signal lenses out for a shoot
filmed a whole video with them and the
video looks really really really nice so
before i get into comparing let me show
you like some real world examples what
these lenses look like when used on set
my goal here was just to make this look
as nice as possible and these lenses
actually helped a lot first off these
are prototype lenses they're super cool
they're super fancy i'm super thankful
that we got to use these that being said
what you're about to see is and what
you're about to hear is all 100 honest
check this out the first thing i noticed
when filming with these is that they are
incredibly crisp what is what does that
mean what does crisp mean when you start
taking a look at some of these frames
here you start seeing that like across
the image from the farthest pixel on one
end of the frame to the other it is
incredibly consistent minimal vignetting
when you look at that image you're like
wow that looks cool we actually have
incredibly minimal lighting here we're
not doing anything fancy on set i do
have a slight color grade applied to it
let me flip that on and off here so you
can see
very minor shift it obviously does help
a little bit but
i'm not doctoring the image by any means
literally all we have in this scene is a
tiny light we have literally one light
panel a one aperture led light in the
scene that is the only like production
light but when you look at this frame
you can tell there is a certain amount
of sharpness and clarity to the image
this is the kind of stuff i'm starting
to notice with these lenses it's
something subtle uh and that's that's
the big thing with these lenses here
it's like they give you those
improvements that that bump the quality
of your piece from something you'd see
shot on a normal dslr to something you
would imagine seeing blown up on a
theater screen or on your big screen tv
at home it's stuff that holds up to that
amount of scrutiny and level of detail
so i've been painting these for a while
working on the forest now it's actually
a really cool technique i learned so
when you're painting miniatures trying
to do details is really really hard but
miniatures also lend themselves to a
technique called dry brushing and dry
brushing is basically where you just put
a little bit of paint on a brush and
then you utilize the texture of a
surface to
pull that paint off the brush you can
see it here in these mountains for
example so if you look closely up here
you can see these little grooves of snow
and rock and that's created by dry
brushing because you just take the brush
and you lightly hit the surface of it
and just those little raised edges catch
the paint i'm actually gonna be doing
dry brushing on this forest here to give
myself fall colors grab a little orange
you wipe it off the brush so it's not
very thick and you just take it you
lightly sweep the surface
and what's going to happen is the raised
parts of your model are going to catch
the paint and the lowered parts of the
model won't have the brush hit it you
basically bring up the detail and it's
really really handy it's really really
easy and just makes it look really good
it's so much easier than like having to
paint and selectively hit all the raised
parts of a model you can just brush it
with your brush consider subscribing to
the channel if you are not already
subscribed because we constantly are
trying new things and learning new
things and sharing that knowledge with
you guys it's a lot of fun amigos little
bob ross corner here there are no
mistakes just happy little accidents
so these lines look cool in practice
they were working really well they're
super sharp the footage looks great i
think this is the best looking video
i've ever shot pretty good review right
now let's take a look though at some of
the back to back comparisons i did so
you can see exactly
what's going on with these lenses versus
some of the more basic lenses that we're
traditionally using so i've grouped up
all of our lenses here so let's start
with some 24 how about that that's
that's a good example i think we have a
bunch of 24 mil lenses that we can
really look at back to back we have our
canon l series 24 millimeter prime lens
we have our sigma 24 millimeter prime
lens just a little flip back and forth
canon
sigma canon
sigma all right so we can't really see
too much just yet what else do we have
on here we have sigma's 18 to 35 zoom
lens at 24 millimeters and so let's go
back and forth between the prime version
of the sigma versus the zoom here we go
prime zoom
prime
zoom okay so that's that's you can see
it quickly there the difference in those
two sigma lenses is already very
significant we do have a little bit of
distortion we have a little bit of
vignetting between these two lenses
what's our last one here what do we got
here oh yes now this is our 17 to 55
lens this is one of the oldest lenses we
have it's the efs 17 to 55 mil let's go
a little more scientific here i'm just
going to zoom in i'm going to blow this
up and take a look at the footage at
like 400
this is where you're going to start to
see what's going on here now we are
zoomed in 400 percent we have so we have
our canon l series prime we have our
sigma
prime
sigma zoom
and 1755 here
so the biggest thing i'm seeing here is
that the canon 24 millimeter l series
lens gives everything a slight magenta
hue shift i'm not sure what's going on
here but if you look at the colors here
versus the sigma prime
right here there is a very stark
difference in the color
that the lens is getting and it's crazy
to think about this but through the
amount of coatings that go on the glass
like anti-reflection anti-flare glare
and then also just simply the physics of
light you won't find that lenses do
shift the color of your footage the
advantage of these sigma ones over the
canon so far is that they are giving us
much more accurate color between the two
sigma lenses not a huge difference in
color this is the zoom and you can see
there is actually a little bit of a
slight purple bluish magenta shift once
again
between the prime right now i'd say the
the prime is still the most accurate for
color
but right there boom big difference
between the this is the sigma prime and
that's the sigma zoom let's go to our
1855. now this one this one is straight
up suffering from a lack of sharpness
and that's that's like the most basic
one i think that right there outlines
what exactly is happening when you're
using these higher end lenses versus
these ones more accurate colors no
distortion on the sides of your frames
no vignetting and last but not least
just simply more sharpness those kind of
combine to give you that high quality
cinematic image that you expect to see
in a movie or a great tv show
[Music]
i can't wait